let's all get our hands off our dicks
and uh get them
all right all right back to [ __ ] talking
back to [ __ ]
with the final category the best episode
of trash taste now obviously we have uh
taken out any other guest episodes
because the guests are on a completely
different calendar this is just the boys
chatting as the boys do honestly we kind
of pick these episodes um so this is
this is
nominations we had nominations for so
many so many episodes so we were just
like
what were the funnest ones for us to
film so this this not only is like our
favorite episode or hopefully you know
one of our favorite episodes but these
are the episodes that we want you guys
to personally go check out because these
are the ones that we personally love
yeah but uh yeah let's check out the
nominees all right so
how not to buy anime figures i remember
filming this episode
and this was the first episode that i
filmed and i was like holy [ __ ] i didn't
know being on camera could be that fun
yeah because that was one of the first
like times where you were like fully
fully like outside yeah yeah yeah
right yeah [ __ ] hell and just the
just just the real solo carrying the
performance and just like the
this was the first one where i look back
at and i'm just like man that was that
was a banger episode yeah we
it was one of those things when we had
all our videos ready to go and the
episode wasn't out
that we i think we were definitely like
i think we've just done like a genius
big brain play
yeah and we made this yeah we really did
we were like i
i went live even though i remember i
[ __ ] fell asleep i didn't schedule my
video
that's right so this whole thing had
like three videos on our own channels to
go up at the same time
yeah and i uh i was asleep and i forgot
to schedule it so
yeah both their videos went up i got so
many messages being angry like where's
connor's part
and i panicked and woked up lately but i
think yeah like accumulatively between
the episode and our three individual
episodes i think there's a mass like
9 million views 10 million views which
is [ __ ] [ __ ] insane
crazy i really do think that this was
the episode that really
shot trash taste up and put us on the
map basically definitely
it pushed a lot of our audience who
maybe weren't too you know yeah it's
you know you can say check out my new
channel it's like well so does everyone
yeah everyone [ __ ] does all right
yeah to actually give them an incentive
to go check it out and then you know
maybe stick around i feel like this was
a difference between our core fan base
being like oh
it's my favorite big youtubers collabing
together to oh they actually make
really funny and good content right
because this is i was really proud of
this episode
and then we got episode 12 which is the
college horror stories which
i personally [ __ ] it's just like a
comfort episode i like this one
i mean to me this has like i in terms of
like density of great stories
this one's a [ __ ] bad truth this has
so many good stories
so much weird [ __ ] happens in college i
know right
i remember like going like before going
on this episode i was like maybe i have
like
i have like a clue of what i'm going to
talk about and then they go on it and
then so many
different stories just like flood back
in and i was like oh i forgot that
happened
this was the one episode that made me
regret not living in a dorm
i was like [ __ ] such an insane i was
like [ __ ] i wish i lived in the door
after hearing your guys anyone who is
deciding to go to college go
go go the life stories and experiences
you will get will be worth
and then we have episode 16 the worst
fandoms in anime it's one of the again
it's a personal favorite varsity yeah
but this is the only one that we love uh
this was [ __ ] so
fun to film um and i'm sad that it
didn't get nominated for more other
categories
because it was just so [ __ ] fun
ranting about
being in the anime community which we
are right and just and i feel like
that's why
not many people like think about this or
remember it but like me personally
i remember this episode whenever i want
to rant about anything that's going on
the anime community
oh yeah we have two best episodes back
to back sixteen
and then seventeen oh the japanese food
you've never tried episode i
[ __ ] love this [ __ ] fantasy this
is where the wine
meme came from is this episode is just
iconic
because i i can't believe it took us
like 17
episodes to argue about food and then
this this just like opened the
floodgates and after this episode we
couldn't stop talking about food
this feels like episode seven yeah i was
like what were we doing for 16 episodes
yeah
like like arguing about food is like an
iconic part of trash taste
and it took 17 episodes for that to
happen it does not feel like a 17
episodes for that to happen
and then of course we have the infamous
episode 25.
i love the title episode oh i love it i
just think there's just like we nailed
everything in there yeah
like we hit all the beats i just like i
we we
that that episode perfectly showed our
personalities
oh yeah
yeah that episode to me like film that
episode was so fun because not only was
like everyone on their a game
but we were just bouncing each other
bouncing off each other so perfectly
like
i remember filming filming this episode
and being like wow we really are drift
compatible
man our horoscopes really do alive yeah
and then we have episode what number is
that we're roasting our horrible anime
taste
we like to say that we're not an anime
podcast yeah but god damn was this fun
to film oh yeah
i think we're a a podcast that just
happens to have three people who want
your [ __ ] ton of anime yeah
occasionally yeah yeah exactly and i
mean to me this was just really fun to
film and just like i
just the mailing moment was just like
the cherry on top
like i i feel like out of everyone this
one ended ended on the biggest bang
just mailing really revealing her
degeneracy that just came out of [ __ ]
nowhere
um and we revived the three by three
trend as well yeah which i would [ __ ]
nuts
which i guess we'll be doing more of in
future yeah yeah i mean it's just it's
just
a great format to judge your lists
bring back three by threes but
we can only choose one i guess the
viewers can choose the viewers can only
choose one
only choose one and this is the best one
of all yeah i mean i've narrowed it down
to six personally and uh how do you guys
choose that top one
i feel like if you're a i feel like the
hentai episode perfectly sums up trash
taste i feel like and i feel like that
could
i will be surprised if it's not that
yeah just because it's so
i mean it's so visceral you see that you
see that title i mean it's like you
react
yeah it's the simplest best right when
it comes to the title it is man it's
like all the other ones you know maybe
you skipped it you didn't skip the
hentai absolutely no no one's skipping
everyone i i do all my homies
i i do feel like if you want to sell
someone on trash taste people are just
going to show the entire episode
just to be like what what is trash it
does coming out really well it's
obviously not the episode you can't show
your friend who is not really into that
kind of stuff
but if they if they're chill with it
show them that episode maybe we'll see
we'll see
by the way i think every episode
deserved it but again
you guys decided on it drum roll please
move on this is the ultimate winner
so the final award for the trash taste
awards the first annual trash taste
awards
best episode for season one goes to
the hentai episode
yes yes well deserved well-deserved
what a banger well done us well done no
about it
let's all
you know it's awesome you're awesome
you're awesome as
oh my well i'm curious though what was
the percentage what was the final what
was the final percentage
this one with 34.6 percent of the money
okay second place with 19 of the vote
was how to not buy anime figurines
oh okay yeah i guess people i thought i
thought the japanese food
one wouldn't yeah yeah yeah yeah but
again like yeah
every episode was an absolute [ __ ]
banger so yeah we wouldn't upload
[Laughter]
i mean there's definitely an episode
that i thought were weaker than others
but there's no episode right that i
thought oh we did a bad show yeah yeah i
was like that's not as good
but yeah sometimes you need the mundane
to make you appreciate the really good
ones that come along
you know because we don't do [ __ ] every
week you know yeah exactly in future
there will be episodes that you might
think oh i'm not reading anything i
don't really talk about that interesting
we record every week that's going to
happen yeah but that's that's like real
life right like you know what
mate comes to you every week with like a
banger story right i mean
everyone does i feel like honestly trash
tastes represents
our friendship off camera as well right
because we
sometimes it it it gets weird after
having recorded this for a full year
or you haven't come i have a
conversation with one of these two and i
can't remember if i've
had this conversation on trash taste or
off trash taste like
yeah but yeah i mean wow i don't even
know what to say man
i don't know i don't know what well i've
i've said everything i'm just saying
i'm very grateful for everything you
know some great mates grateful that
the channel's doing so well you know
thank you guys for an entire year
it's been [ __ ] insane and uh man
there's plenty more where that came from
yeah i mean again like we're moving to
the new studio soon so we're hoping to
that's going to be like the real end of
season one yeah
that'll be the end of season one yeah
there'll be a bunch of episodes after
this one goes up but the
real yeah the exactly it's the ovs the
real season two start of the news
it's like the spider-man movie after you
know after um was it
after the like avengers movie yeah it's
like this is the real end of phase three
okay okay mom yeah